pour une partie des français le pass
sanitaire ne passe toujours pas ce
mercredi un nouveau rassemblement à
l'appel de florian philippot s'est
déroulée devant le sénat pour protester
contre cette mesure sanitaire le
président des patriotes ne mâche pas ses
mots face à la politique du gouvernement
monsieur verrons nous a dit hier à deux
mois si on met pas le passage d'ida on
va devoir confiné qui me cite un seul
pays qui n'a pas le passé les terres et
qui a dû re confiné n'y en a pas voilà
n'y en a pas donc en fait c'était des
mensonges ils ne font que mentir voilà
ils ne font que mentir il lui avait dit
on arrive on enlèvera le parce qu'en
s'abaissera ca a baissé il n'enlève pas
le passez moi c'est tout ce que je
retiens c'est que ce sont des menteurs
pathologiques et qu'ils sont là pour
mettre sous cloche le peuple français
alors que la contestation gronde est ce
mercredi devant le sénat à l'intérieur
du palais du luxembourg
les sénateurs planchait sur le texte
destiné à prolonger le pass annie terre
les parlementaires de la commission des
lois se sont mis d'accord sur un projet
de loi modifié qui limite l'utilisation
du passani terre à la date du 28 février
2000 22 contre le 31 juillet
initialement prévu on ne veut pas donner
de chèque en blanc au gouvernement il
nous paraît essentiel de ne pas dépasser
trois mois et demi entre deux débat
législatif autorisant les mesures et les
adaptant à la réalité de la situation
les libertés sont essentiels quand on
les restreint on ne peut pas laisser le
gouvernement faire ce qu'il veut en
outre parmi les amendements proposés par
philippa on retrouve la possibilité
d'utiliser le passe à lithaire seulement
dans les départements ou moins de 75 %
de la population est vaccinée le but est
d'encourager les plus réfractaires à se
faire injecter le c'est romantique au
vide l'ensemble des sénateurs débattront
de ce projet de loi modifié ce jeudi et
vendredi en cas de désaccord entre
députés et sénateurs une commission
mixte paritaire sera chargé de trouver
un terrain d'entente